what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be talking about
something in the manosphere
that i don't know i just hear guys say a
lot
and i wanted to address but before i
start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified
of my daily videos while you're at it
okay
follow my instagram it's just pearly
things but instead of an ass
it's a z okay so this is what i wanted
to talk about
i started watching manosphere content
like a couple months ago and
it's been so interesting to hear
everything like from a man's point of
view like what men think
the struggles that men go through just
that like i never honestly thought about
or realized
um um i think a lot of men go to the
manosphere because they're really sick
of
how do i say this like girls choosing
the bad boys over the nice guys and then
picking them later as like a last resort
um and a lot of men like their
conclusion has come to be like let's
avoid dating like
all women are toxic all women are this
like why would i sign up to get married
if there was a 50
divorce rate and only a 10 rate of being
happy after like this many years
and i've heard it all i've heard all the
stats i've heard whatever but
here's my two cents on it everything
you're gonna do in life
is hard like most people aren't gonna
become millionaires most people aren't
gonna
become rich does that mean you don't try
you know most people aren't gonna have
happy marriages that's just the truth
does that mean you don't try does that
mean you remove yourself from the game
most people are overweight most people
are going to get out of shape
statistically like in their lifetime
most people will be overweight
in america anyway i mean i know some of
you guys are international so maybe it's
not the same overseas but you guys see
what i'm saying like
life in general anything worth having is
hard
and guys will be like oh i did all the
right things last time and i got burned
so what you know there's like there's
been times when i've done all the right
things
and i've gotten burned like getting
burned in life
it happens and if your answer to that is
oh i'm not gonna date at all like women
are too far gone
i think that's more of a reflection of
you and your ability to pick than it is
women
genuinely women have their problems i'm
not
gonna discount that women can be evil
women can be manipulative
and women can be downright terrible but
maybe the solution is cultivating better
a better ability to pick
rather than blaming the world because i
see women do this too they'll say men
are trash men or trashmen are the worst
and
you know when you have that mindset it's
like
why don't you cultivate your ability to
pick so my two cents
in the manosphere let me know if you
guys agree or you disagree
um don't forget to subscribe and sign up
i'm doing
um members only surveys from now on so
if you guys like the surveys that i do
on my channel that are like
that um where i asked like would you
rather date
whatever i'm gonna start doing those
just for members
so yeah i will talk to you guys next
time